Tom Ellis might not be firing up the
screen as the devilish Lucifer Morning
Star but he's kept himself busy since
his hit show here's what he's been up to
prior to his role as Lucifer morning
star Tom Ellis had some success in other
popular shows which could have
catapulted him to the same level of Fame
that Lucifer did except his character
arcs never quite lasted in 2007 Ellis
was cast as Thomas Milligan in Doctor
Who he was initially introduced during
an alternate timeline the year that
never was as a doctor of a team
rebelling against a Saxon Master he and
the 10th doctor's companion and Martha
Jones engaged in a flirtation that
continued into the proper timeline the
two eventually got engaged with the
promise that Thomas would surely return
to the series however his character was
scrapped with Martha instead marrying
Mickey Smith another previous companion
Ellis suffered a similar fate in 2013
when he was cast to play Robin Hood in
Once Upon a Time the series was known
for bringing well-known fairy tale
characters to life this version of Robin
Hood was cunning and resourceful so it
came as no surprise that he eventually
became a staple character in the show
however Ellis was cast with Shawn
Maguire cutting his time in the magical
land of Storybrook short similarly his
Merlin character sen red experienced a
short time on the show as he was killed
off after a handful of episodes when Fox
made the decision to cut ties with
Lucifer viewers were outraged Lucifer
fans tried to save the show by launching
a Twitter campaign with the hash save
Lucifer and pickup Lucifer the show
became the number one trending topic on
the platform with over 3 million tweets
and retweets proving just how important
the series has become to fans luckily
Netflix answered the call and brought
season 4 to its platform Lucifer enjoyed
success on Netflix as the streamer
brought it back for a total of three
seasons however this caused some
apparent tension as contract disputes
between Tom Ellis and the studio
threatened a final conclusion for the
Beloved characters in the spring of 2020
it was reported that production on
season 6 was in Jeopardy as the
renegotiations between Ellis and Warner
Brothers came to a halt in Insider told
TV line that the goal was to keep ellis
happy with the final negotiations
however there was also a limit while
neither Warner Brothers nor Ellis's
spokesperson ever commented on the
speculation the delay was caused for
concern thankfully all parties were able
to pull things together and provide fans
with an ending that they had worked so
hard to get at the core of all of these
decisions it's business in 2022 Netflix
debuted an adaptation of Neil gaiman's
acclaimed comic book series The Sandman
the show follows Morpheus one of the
seven endlesss that embody and control
the forces of nature morphus is the Lord
of dreams and when he's captured his
realm of Dreams is sent into absolute
chaos aside from morphe and his other
endless siblings a popular character
from gamon's comic is Lucifer the ruler
of hell since both have existed in the
DC Comics continuity Tom Ellis's version
of Lucifer is Loosely based on gamon's
work and some fans wondered why Ellis
wasn't brought back to play Lucifer in
the Sandman however the reason is quite
simple the character Ellis portrayed is
simply too different from the one in the
Sandman on X formerly known as Twitter a
fan asked gaman to explain why Ellis was
recast he said because is Lucifer while
inspired by the Lucifer and Sandman is
so far away in terms of Sandman
continuity by the end of Lucifer that
it's easier on everyone to go back to
the version in the comics plus by seeing
an entirely new version of Lucifer fans
are now able to have a new experience
when watching the Sandman gamman said
that he still admires The Lovable
version of Lucifer that Ellis played but
he knew that recasting the character was
the right choice therefore Game of
Thrones actor gwendelyn Christie was
brought in as a colder and more brutal
Lucifer which is also more accurate to
the story from the Sandman Lucifer
wrapped in 2021 in the middle of the
covid-19 pandemic prior to the
restrictions Tom Ellis had said that he
would travel back and forth between LA
and the UK in order to spend time with
his children however with the lockdown
that proved impossible contributed to
him taking a break from acting once
Lucifer ended speaking on the reign with
Josh Smith podcast Ellis reflected on
how he might not be able to see his
children for months describing the
experience as being terrible luckily he
found that he could work through the
torment in therapy stating I've spoken
to a therapist for years now and I think
it's one of the most helpful tools that
I found in my life can we please just
focus on what truly matters here this is
especially the case as he gets older
Ellis is beginning to put different
things in perspective for the sake of
his family the actor has a large family
as he shares two daughters Florence and
Marney with his ex-wife Tams and
outweight he also has a daughter named
Norah from his previous relationship
with Estelle Morgan currently Ellis is
married to producer and screenwriter
Megan Oppenheimer the murder of George
Floyd by a police officer in Minneapolis
Minnesota caused a wave of protest
against police brutality that exploded
worldwide in 2020 during this time Tom
ell became heavily involved in the
movement against racial profiling and
with Lucifer being over he dedicated
some of his resources to the cause in an
interview with square mile Ellis
explained how he wanted to use his star
power as a voice for those who didn't
have one and it's thanks to his wife
Megan Oppenheimer she went to school
with Brandon Kyle Goodman best known for
his voice acting in big mouth after the
murder of George Floyd Goodman shared
his thoughts and experiences as a black
man on Instagram he would engage in
conversations with Oppenheimer which in
turn brought Ellis in as well Ellis
decided to use his large platform as a
space to spread constructive
conversations together they launch black
folks a weekly series of conversations
between Goodman and other black guests
hosted on Ellis's popular Instagram
account for Ellis it was a chance for
him to do some good speaking to square
mile he said I've got quite a big social
media following now it's the best thing
I've ever done with my social media I
want to encourage and invite more
conversation like that Brandon is so
brilliantly articulate and just
generally compassionate as a person as
you can see the devil does indeed wear
PR a major issue that many actors come
across as being typ cast and this would
especially be the case when an actor
plays a television character over a span
of several years eventually audiences
begin to associate the actor with the
character as that's what they're most
notable for portraying and this is
exactly what Tom Ellis wanted to prevent
from happening to him in his career
because he played the character of
Lucifer for so long Ellis is looking to
Branch out and explore other kinds of
roles which is likely why he's been so
hesitant to jump into anything too
quickly in his interview with square
mile Ellis said I'm going to find myself
in that similar territory and that
people are going to expect one thing
from me now and I would like to surprise
them and do something completely
different that's always been my thought
process luckily Ellis has taken the past
few years to compile a list of things
he'd like to accomplish in his career
which he shared with square mile from
working on Broadway to portraying
Benedict and much to do about nothing
Ellis has many plans and at the top of
that list working with his wife Megan
Oppenheimer it's thanks to the Magic
Touch of Tom Ellis's wife Megan
Oppenheimer that he's returning to
Hollywood after his much needed break
Ellis shares that he met Oppenheimer
while shooting the pilot episode Phil
Looper they were introduced through a
mutual friend who knew that the two
would hit it off it seems as though they
were correct as the two have been
happily married since 2019 Oppenheimer
works as a producer and screenwriter she
is the creator of the Hulu series tell
me lies starring Grace Van Patton she
also wrote for the popular AMC series
Fear The Walking Dead before it was
announced that she'd partner with Reese
Witherspoon to work on the drama please
don't go Ellison Oppenheimer are teaming
up for the first time together for their
new series second wife the series is a
dark comedy that stars Emma Roberts
along alongside Ellis as they play a
couple who impulsively get married and
realize they don't know each other now
that Tom Ellis seems ready to head back
into the Limelight he's got a few
projects in the works in addition to
accomplishing his dream of working with
his wife Megan Oppenheimer and their
series second wife Ellis has another
series he set to star in called
Washington black Hulu's adaptation of
the novel of the same name Washington
black will see Ellis co-star with this
is us star Sterling K Brown and Ernest
Kingsley Jr who will play the aonomus
protagonist among others The Story
begins then 19th century on a sugar
Plantation in Barbados from where the
young character of George Washington
black tries to escape his journey brings
him into contact with Brown's character
medwin Harris who becomes a kind of
Mentor for him Ellis portrays the quirky
inventor Christopher wild also known as
titch his family owns the plantation but
titch is exceedingly different from his
cruel brother and becomes another friend
to Washington during his adventures well
come on who's in for most of his career
Tom Ellis is stuck to the small screen
however thanks to the fame that Lucifer
has given him Ellis now has the
opportunity to reach New Heights and it
seems like that's just what he's going
to do as the actor does have something
in the works for the big screen he sets
a star in an upcoming romantic comedy
called players opposite Jane the Virgin
Le Gina Rodriguez players is described
as a similar concept to that of the 2005
Will Smith film hitch which follows Ava
Mendes as Sarah as she tries to expose
Smith's hitch a professional date doctor
who helps shy men approach and
successfully date women of course Sarah
Falls for hitch realizing that his job
isn't exactly the misogynist career she
initially thought it was players follows
a similar formula with Rodriguez's Mac
making a habit of creating hookup plays
with her friends but of course she
eventually Falls hard for one of the men
she goes after who is portrayed by Ellis
the film also Stars Damon Wayne Jr and
Joel Courtney from the kissing booth
it's produced by La La Land producer
Mark Platt ever since Tom Ellis lent his
voice to the animated series The Great
North it seems that his taste for voice
acting has grown as he's also set to
voice a character in the Netflix
animated series exploding kittens based
on the popular card game exploding
kittens is not only getting an animated
series but also a mobile game to
accompany it this marks the first time
that Netflix will launch a series and a
video game at the same time from the
same franchise the series follows the
conflict between Heaven and Hell as it
spills out onto Earth after both God and
the devil arrive there but here's the
twist they arrive in the bodies of cats
casting Ellis seems like a no-brainer as
this is in his first rodeo when it comes
to portraying Divine characters however
as he's already announced his hesitance
at being typ cast it stands the reason
that exploding kittens will will offer
audiences something entirely different
from the squabbles Between Heaven and
Hell depicted in Lucifer in addition to
Ellis the Animated Series will feature
the voices of Lucy Lou sasher Zeda and
Abraham Lim among
[Music]
others